[Music]
[Applause]
the weekend we make way for the
popular co-host of pro football talk
live on peacock
chris sims the former nfl quarterback
who joins us on the program chris thanks
for joining us
let me start with the quarterback we are
most likely to not
see next season phillip rivers ben
roethlisberger drew brees
okay the one we're most likely not to
see i i mean i think it's uh really
up in the air for all three of them i'll
say
i don't see big ben i think big ben is
gonna try to give it one more year
all right so i'm gonna say that and i
think for what he's done for the
pittsburgh
organization if he says he wants to come
back one more year they'll probably let
him
the drew brees philip rivers won you
know i think phillip rivers is probably
the guy i would say is the most likely
we've
we won't see again drew brees i think
it's a little bit
like ben roethlisberger if he says he
wants to come back
they're going to bring him back but i do
get a feel or a sense just by some of
the comments sean payton made during the
year that they'd like to move on a
little bit
but i think rivers would probably be the
leader in the clubhouse on that one
who deserves the heat for the steelers
loss last night
well um you know overall
just the whole offensive unit the
approach everything they did
you know towards the end of the year you
know i think i came on a few weeks ago
it's one thing to be predictable it's
one thing to be
predictable within your predictability i
mean okay we're going to
we're going to throw the ball and now
you know we're going to throw the ball
off
so they're predictably predictable right
that's the better way to say it see me
and
me in english aren't always all that
good but that's the way
to say that that's why they pay you the
big bucks me talk pretty much yeah yeah
me talk pretty right
me play football me blonde i mean not
that smart
so but but that's like i think that's it
though
when you talk about it it's we know
they're going to throw the ball okay and
then to compound it
we know they're going to throw the ball
five yards down the field
you know over the middle of the middle
of the ball middle of the field that
area and i think that's really the issue
i mean come on snap over the head bad
interception over the running backs head
in a formation and a playset that they
usually don't do
play action one-man route you know then
they get into the next drive and it's a
third and one
and they can't even run the ball for a
yard if they really want to because
that's not what they are
so it's really overall just the offense
in general and of course big ben's a big
part of that
by the way we're focusing on the teams
that lost over the weekend
right now and then we'll talk about you
know moving forward so just so you know
um the rams and the seahawks you know
i'm not surprised at what happened i'm
surprised at how it happened
it really felt like the rams that was
the varsity in seattle was a junior
varsity
how did that happen at home to seattle
yeah well the rams defense is special
that's the first thing
and the one thing i i say when i really
break down ram seahawks matchups too you
got to remember the rams were built to
beat the seahawks you know when sean
mcvay took over
seahawks were king of the world you know
so you're going to build your team to
wait how are we going to win our
division and that was you know priority
number one
so really on the field player for player
they match up well with them
and then the the defense for the rams
you know
just what they do to the seahawks they
got a front four that can contain
russell wilson they got a dk metcalf
eraser and jalen ramsey
and i think the big thing is just to
focus on the seahawks like you're saying
they need another idea guy on the
offensive side of the ball i like brian
schottenheimer
but it's like maybe like i would say
with greg roman in baltimore it might be
one of those things where you go we need
to bring a passing game coordinator in
here
to just infuse a few more ideas and and
things into our offense because as you
see it's very stale
and teams really caught on to it the
last four or five weeks of the year
uh how should washington fans feel today
um that their organizations going in the
right direction there's a lot to be
excited about
uh i don't think taylor heineke is going
to be the future of the franchise but
either way that was amazing with what
the hell we saw the other night
i mean right i don't know i just kept
going all right here comes the blowout
what he did whoa unbelievable all right
here comes the blowout and then he'd
pull out another unbelievable football
play
but between that defense you know some
of the guys they got
all over there you know even in the
secondary they got a good offensive line
they got a star receiver and terry
mclaren
antonio gibson who was playing hurt here
at the end of the year is a really damn
good running back dan
they're a team i would say like they get
this quarterback situation figured out
watch out for washington in 2021. what
happened to the titans
the titans ran into a healthy baltimore
ravens defense
the first time they played there was no
brandon williams or calais campbell
they dominated the line of scrimmage the
ravens defensive line brandon
williams class campbell matt judon they
kicked butt and i think the rookie
linebackers they have and patrick queen
and malik harrison too
you know the fact that they got to see
tennessee earlier
i think helped them how to defend the
run game and what to do properly there
was really a big thing
and then those two corners in the back
end the fact that you can rely on them
and go wait we got to stop derek henry
and then we got to put you guys in an
island versus aj brown and corey davis
you know that that's that's a special
defensive unit
and and of course you know that offense
for the baltimore ravens and their
physicality
and lamar dan if they just throw it just
enough like we saw yesterday with
hollywood brown
outside the numbers and just attack that
part of the field to where defenses have
to defend it
it's going to help their offense out big
time it's going to open up the running
lanes and everything like that i thought
that was one of the underrated
aspects of the game yesterday i guess i
should mention the bears
to be professional sure i guess the one
question i have is
you know what do you do with mitchell
trubisky
i feel like they're going to bring them
back
to a one or two year deal
and go okay we're going to play the
style of football we played here
the last five or six weeks of the year
but now we're going to grow that
as far as the rolodex plays that can
come off
of attack stop trying to be the kansas
city chiefs in the pa and patrick
mahomes that's not going to happen in
chicago that's not who you are
so yeah they got to go all in on this
offensive approach but i don't know i'm
one that i look at it and just go
the bears are closer to the top than the
bottom
and if they can guarantee me they're
going to get some awesome
slam dunk franchise quarterback then
okay you make the move but if we're
gonna go with like
oh we're gonna bring in nick foles in
and maybe he can beat the guy then
don't waste your time go with mitchell
trubisky if matthew stafford's available
okay then maybe you do think about that
but i would expect to see trubisky back
is chris sims on loan from nbc sports um
if you were going to reseed right now
is anything changed in the nfc and afc
for you heading into the next round of
the playoffs
oh that's a good question i uh let me
see here as i just look at that
[Music]
i don't know i think this is what i
would probably look at right now
i i don't think anything's changed for
me in the nfc
um i think that i would probably say
yeah i think i would go
green bay the saints the bucks right
there on the edge of those guys and the
rams right
there in a close one as well but in the
afc
you know kansas city's the king but that
builds
baltimore ravens for number two seed or
number two spot in the afc hierarchy
right now i think that's very close i
think that's a scary matchup for buffalo
for this week
you know we saw what that colts
offensive line did to that
bill's defense the colts outplayed the
buffalo bills the bills just had the
best player on the field and josh allen
and that's why they overcame it but i
would be worried about that running
attack in lamar jackson versus buffalo
this week
we've talked about this before i applaud
cleveland for finally understanding
who they are right and i said if
stefanski was on the sidelines i would
have picked them to beat pittsburgh well
as it turned out they didn't need
him on the sidelines the identity that
they have
can that identity beat kansas city and
kansas city
i think it can give them a tough time i
don't know if their defense is good
enough
to pull through against kansas city i do
think that their offense could be good
enough to where
they can maybe do what we saw the colts
do to the buffalo bills the other day
run the ball keep their offense on the
field
run out the clock keep mahomes next to
the gatorade bottles and everything like
that
and you got a chance to make the game
interesting certainly but i think it
would worry me
is more that brown's defense and i know
they're going to be healthy with some
guys being back but it's not a very good
unit and a week off with andy reid and
patrick mahomes i think that could be
scary
what would you do with desean watson if
you were the gm of the texans
well i would never give deshawn watson
away
for less than anything just absolutely
jaw-dropping
unbelievable i can't say no to that
trade offer
uh dan the the biggest like perplexing
thing to me
desean watson no doubt one of the five
best quarterbacks in the game
you told him going into this process you
were gonna let him have a say
or at least be in the conversation and
then
we get to this moment and the guy that
he kind of vouched for and eric the
enemy
you don't even interview him i don't
know what else to say to houston other
than that you're just you're stupid
i don't know you interview the guy just
to say to your quarterback who's the
star of your team
hey we interviewed the guy you talked
about hey it didn't work
out you know blah blah blah blah blah
but you do that for just
that element alone and that's what i
don't understand and they're in a weird
spot down there right now
would you trade him to miami for tua
and let's say you get a couple of
first-round draft picks
um it would have to be a lot of
first-round drop picks
it would be and i don't know if i would
do that right now i don't know i think
because tua to me at this it's still up
in the air
for what tua is you know i'm not sold on
tua is definitely a franchise
like we got our guy for 10 years i'm not
sure about that yet i don't mean
disrespect to him i'm rooting for him
but i think we all saw the same thing at
the end of the year it's a little
concerning and i'm not sure i'm ready to
stamp it and just go
i like what i saw and he's the guy for
the future
thank you chris as always we appreciate
your time we love that you
wrap up the weekend and uh your own
style there thanks for joining us tell
uh florio we said hello
i will say say hi to the guys be good
dan that's chris sims
he uh is one of the stars of pro
football talk live
on uh peacock six to nine
every monday through friday